Okay, so we started with one whole cake. We know one-half of it was eaten. So, I
need to subtract off half of my cake. I also know that 3 10th of the remaining
half of the cake was also eaten. So, I have 3 10th of a half. I remember of
means multiply. So, I need to take 3 10th and multiply it by a half. And this 3
10th of a half was eaten, so I need to subtract it off as well. So, I have one
whole cake minus half a cake minus 3 10th of a one-half cake. I'm going to clear
this up and take out the words. So, I have 1 for one whole cake, minus a half,
and then 3 20th. I got 3 20th by doing the multiplication here. I have 3 over
20, or 3 20th. To subtract fractions, I know I need to find a common
denominator. I don't have to worry about the 1 when finding a common
denominator. I can change 1 to 2 halves, 3 3rd, or 4 4th. I can change it into
anything pretty easily. For 2 and 20, I know the least common multiple, or the
least common denominator, is 20. It's the smallest number that both 2 and 20 go
into. I can also do this using my factor tree. I know the common factor for 2
and 20 is 2. The other factor of 2 is 1, and the other factor of 20 is 10. 1
times 2 times 10 makes 20. So, the change one-half to 20th, I know I need to
multiply by 10 over 10. So, one-half is the same thing as 10 20th. For 3 20ths,
I don't need to multiply by anything. I already have 20th so I just keep the
numerator. But, I need to change this 1. To change the 1, I'm going to multiply
by 20 over 20. I know 20 20th is still one whole. So, 20 20th minus 10 20th is
10 20th. This should make sense because I know if I start with one whole cake
and subtract off half of it, I should still have half of it left. 10 20th is
really the same as one-half. Now, I still need to subtract off my 3 20th. So, 10
20th minus 3 20th is 7 20th. If you said 7 20th, excellent work.